so do you do anything for Valentine's
Day do you go all out or use chill no
well you know what I used to do a lie
yeah was I was always waitressing on
Valentine's Day
me too yeah I was a waitress for a
really long time but the real fun is
actually the day before Valentine's
which is uh I know where you're going
with this
yes that is that's the day you have the
most cash sales because that's because
in people don't want you to follow that
trail because no one's ever birthday
yeah that's how my restaurant managers
day yeah yeah so they will seeing if
you're ever waited tables it's so sad
but it's real yeah like and they pay
with cash and you're like you're like
yep
like why are all my sales cash I spent a
lot of holidays you know waiting tables
as well yeah oh don't get how hard you
work at it they're always like I need
this now and like so do the other seven
tables yeah something yeah it turns out
you weren't special I have to wait on
everyone anyway but did you have any
other jobs like before like hitting it
big oh well I was a personal trainer for
about two weeks I worked at a gym but I
would have never been a personal trainer
I shouldn't have been so you like really
I that takes a lot like I would never
know did you feel comfortable doing that
no you have to know all the things no
comfort no comfort no no motivation it's
like people are coming to me to be
motivated and I didn't have anything
anything for that you're like you know
what do ten times or eight I don't yeah
like yeah I'm used to in wraps or none I
don't care what you do I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this